je préfère mourir que de retourner à
dubaï
c'est ce qu'a dit andré gauthier
lorsqu'il a été arrêté à oman en mars
dernier il risque maintenant d'être
extradé aux émirats arabes unis où il
pourrait écoper de 14 en prison l'homme
de 65 ans originaire de la baie a été
arrêté en 2015 est condamné à huit ans
de prison dans une affaire de fraude
il a été libéré après un an et demi en
attendant que sa cause soit portée en
appel
mais sans passeport et sans papiers
selon ses proches et son avocate
andré gauthier aurait découvert des
irrégularités financières dans les
activités de son entreprise
la minière god i et mais lorsqu'il
aurait voulu exposer une présumée fraude
de 30 millions de dollars aux autorités
les personnes impliquées dans le
stratagème avait déjà quitté dubaï parce
que le juge il le dit clairement comme
ça c'est monsieur je sais vous avez rien
fait mais vous êtes le seul la compagnie
est encore ici vous êtes le président la
compagnie que vous êtes encore ici vous
partirez pas ça préoccupe pas à la fin
du mois de mars
andré ghodsi s'est déplacé à au monde
pour tenter d'obtenir des documents
consulat du canada lui permettant
quitter le pays
c'est à ce moment qu'il a été de nouveau
arrêté il est dans un point de bascule
oman doivent se débarrasser de cet
individu là qui ont rien fait sur le
territoire mais qui son poignet avec une
patate chaude
d'un côté du bail dit on le veut ici et
le canada semble-t-il ben on s'est quand
même des contacts avec les ambassadeurs
en contact avec le gouvernement du
canada depuis trois ans la famille
estime que le dossier n'avance pas assez
vite et a fait appel aux députés richard
martel
on a rencontré madame free l'homme pur
lui à des situations d'urgence il faut
le ramener au canada le plus vite
possible
le cabinet de la ministre des affaires
étrangères nous a fait savoir que le
gouvernement du canada suivait de très
près ce dossier
la secrétaire parlementaire a discuté du
cas d'andré gauthier directement avec
les représentants du gouvernement
domaine ici ça rappelle radio canada
saguenay